[Music]
derek's in bristol tennessee hey derek
how are you
hey dave how are you better than i
deserve how can we help
uh yeah just come across your books your
money makeover
book and your videos about a month ago i
was very intrigued
um i'm 29 years old i work
at a prison in little town in
coburn virginia
i sold about fifty thousand dollars
worth of sports cards last week
whoa uh to kind of get into
i mean i think clayton said i've been a
little boy and just the market has
tripled and quadrupled the last little
bit
that's a little bit more than just
intrigue derek that means you're
you're in huh yeah oh yeah i mean it
really helped me
uh like i said i've been watching things
and
i've obviously noticed i've did some bad
stuff in the past by
financing vehicles this is kind of where
i'm at i've only got four paid like four
uh finances that i've got i've got a
truck payment
a van payment for my wife i got two kids
and i also run a lawn business part-time
on the side
okay what's your question uh well my
question is i got fifty thousand dollars
i owe twenty nine thousand on my truck
uh eighteen thousand on the van
and i owe twelve thousand dollars on my
mower the other the other the fourth
payment was my house of course
uh but my question is do i pay off my
trucking van
and i'll still have three thousand
dollars roughly left over
my mower is zero percent interest um
like i said i bought that for my
business i do on the side
that i bring in about uh one probably
like one point five thousand
uh profit a month so it'll basically pay
off itself so i was just wondering
would it be best to just pay off my
trucking van and then
go to the next step of the baby step
yeah
um let's correct a couple things okay
zero percent having anything to do with
anything
the other thing is that mower's not
going to pay itself off you're going to
keep cutting grass and pay it off
because if you quit cutting grass that
mower sitting there by itself in the
garage ain't going to pay off anything
absolutely so that's a misnomer that
this thing is somehow on autopilot to
pay itself off
so no i would list my debts smallest to
largest and i would pay them in that
order like we teach in baby step two
which means i'm gonna pay the mower off
and mama's car off in a big chunk on
your truck and then i'm gonna knock your
truck out
with the money you were gonna use to
knock the mower out you still got 12 000
balance on the truck basically in this
scenario and um
you need to knock that out asap not not
in
20 months but like in a few months what
is your total household income
uh i clear after uh
after what i put in my retirement uh
paying my health care insurance stuff
like that i think i bring home
i think it's like 1200 a month just with
my prison
my prison job like i said then my mowing
i bring home like
fifteen hundred almost two thousand yeah
does your wife work outside the home
no she's down okay all right well the
uh uh you know that's the thing
uh uh i'm gonna list it in the smallest
to largest i'm gonna pay them off in
that order
uh and of course we teach you to
temporarily stop retirement and then how
quick are you gonna pay off the 12
000 remaining balance on your truck
that's your next goal
but i'm gonna work it right straight
down the line wait a minute wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
you need to sell this
sell the truck yeah this truck you owe
too much i mean
listen when you own things with wheels
and motors totaled up more than half
your annual income which you do
you've got a truck you can't afford even
if it's paid off
so yeah you need to move down in truck
um
that that's what i would do here's the
thing it's very difficult to get ahead
financially you're
you're a car guy you're a motor guy
you're a gearhead
you you know you don't think anything
about buying a 12 000
lawnmower and so uh you know i mean this
is the guy you are so
it's going to be difficult for you to
get this your head around this because
i'm the same
way i grew up everything has got a motor
on it i love it you know
and uh i want one of every one of them
i've never seen something that can go
wooden wooden that i didn't like you
know
and so uh you know the problem is
all those things go down in value and
it's very difficult to
build wealth when they're going down in
value
and um you know i always thought i could
out earn that i always thought and you
made some good money on those sports
cars that's good i'm glad you're out of
them though so
yeah i that's what i would do i'd move
down and truck and
i don't know if you'll do it or not but
that's what you should do
that's what you should do when i first
heard this advice i didn't do it the
first time i heard the advice my
grandfather
who taught me to pull nails out of a
board and straighten them out and put
them in a coffee can because he lived
through the great depression i pulled up
i was high rolling i thought i thought
as a ba and i
roll up in a jaguar in my grandpa's
driveway i'm making money doing real
estate before i went broke in the real
estate business
and um he's like what's that
that's a great granddad question so we
mean what's that he goes
that he's pointed the car and says it's
a jaguar he goes what that cost
and i mean that's 1983 or 84 i said you
know
30 thousand bucks you know which is like
buying a 80 000 car now right
and he he said you're kidding what's it
do
[Laughter]
i said well it's you know it's a fine
european vehicle it's
that time made in you know in um
in england and you know it's this is a
you know
and he goes really
and he said uh and i said and besides
that a car like this will hold its value
and he said what do you mean i said
it'll hold its value and he goes
well in 10 years will it be worth i said
well maybe
20 000 or maybe 15 000 years
i said that's like an investment he goes
my investments go up
granddads are the best man just like pop
pop
pop kept throat punching me over and
over again
so finally i'm just like well he doesn't
understand he didn't know anything
and of course he had started from
nothing and had you know
and didn't ever really invest just save
money but but you know
passed away as a millionaire with just
money and cds but
and coffee cans full of nails you know
and so uh but he's like
i said it's an investment he cocked that
head sideways
really my investments go up that
question from a granddad of
what's that is what's that you're an
idiot what's wrong with you
all rolled into one kind granddaddy
question
a passive aggressive southern
grandfather what's that what's that
that's fantastic what is wrong with you
what's wrong with you
you idiot